abel wandered through the sands a lone
warrior dragging a long dark sword
behind him his black cloak flowing in
the gentle breeze the sword was thirsty
it had been too long since it tasted
blood what had it been a day since he
cut down 10 men in a tavern without
breaking a sweat they'd bled and
screamed like pigs as he diced them into
bloody chunks he couldn't remember their
faces they hadn't earned that very few
combatants had been remarkable enough to
warrant committing to memory it was all
just more dead flesh he took a sip from
his canteen inside did this world hold
no more challenges what a boring
eternity was laying out before him his
burden as the greatest warrior of all
time weighed on him heavier than the
chain it was old and rusty levered over
his shoulder and grasped in one bloody
hand about 15 feet behind him the chain
was connected to a dark stone
sarcophagus that was as much a part of
him as his eyes skin or heart if ever he
was slain in the glorious heat of battle
he'd rise out of it ready to fight and
kill another day all because of the
actions of his worthless
good-for-nothing brother he looked up
when he heard the rush of footsteps and
the clanking of armor warriors or
whatever pass for them around here about
20 of them circled all around him yes
oh yes his grip tightened around his
sword one of the warriors called out
something about him being under arrest
by order of the king for murders beyond
counting abel couldn't help but yawn
words words words why even bother he
dropped the chain and in one fluid
motion he threw his sword in a fraction
of a second it pierced the armor of the
chattering man spearing him through his
formerly beating heart the scream died
in his throat he fell to his knees then
collapsed entirely the other soldiers
sent to kill or apprehend him turn to
their fallen leader and gasp it was that
little gasp that moment of distraction
that sealed their fades abel's face
cracked into a whisper of a grin as he
drew two long daggers from the darkness
of his coat he'd at least try to have
fun with this before the others could
even get over their leader's sudden
death
abel had vaulted forward and begun his
delicate dance of slaughter every swing
found its way through armor and into
skin he sliced throats cleaved off heads
carried blows and pierced hearts there
was barely a single scream cable killed
too quick for screams in what would seem
like the blink of an eye for some the
soldiers around abel fell most dead the
rest dying some looked up to him in
their dying moments in terrified awe of
the efficacy of their killer in their
dying moments they knew that they never
had a chance they might as well have
been facing the glistening scythe of
death himself on the battlefield abel on
the other hand rolled his eyes inside
another pathetic waste of time he sensed
movement in the corner of his eye one of
the wounded soldiers was limping to his
feet trying to use the sword to lever
himself off of the ground with a flick
of each wrist able tossed his knives
into the man killing him instantly it
really was that easy your attempt to
kill me does not offend me he said to
whoever was still able to hear what
offends me is that they would send so
few and that those few would be such
pitiful excuses for soldiers
this wasn't a battle it was a mercy
killing he was ready to turn around grab
the chain and carry on walking when he
felt a sudden pain in his back there was
a slight whistle then another sharp
spike of pain there were now two arrows
sticking out of his back abel turned
surprised and saw a much larger force
standing behind him swordsmen archers
men with clubs and axes and chains the
ones he'd kill were little more than a
distraction this was the real threat
this was a real army perhaps these fools
would give him some actual exercise he
reached into his cloak and pulled out a
mighty obsidian battle axe at the very
least he tried to have a little fun
turning this fighting force into cold
cuts a fog of arrows sailed through the
air as he charged forwards perforating
his body but the injuries didn't slow
him down he lunged slashed and cleaved
even as the weapon struck him he carried
on killing person after person at times
it was almost exciting
almost but not quite by the time he was
done none were left standing 30 arrows
were sticking out of him he'd been cut
deep by more weapons than he could count
on his fingers and toes he was breathing
deeply scarred chest pumping up and down
he coughed blood and cracked his neck
back into place they might have cut him
a little too deep this time no matter
abel fell to his knees feeling the life
draining from him he wondered when he
awoke from the coffin again what the
world would look like sometimes it was
days sometimes weeks months or even
years as he fell forward dying once
again he'd hoped that he'd wake into a
world with a warrior or beast that could
actually challenge him maybe someday
this was one of abel's many lives
hundreds of years before he was
contained by the scp foundation he's
perhaps the greatest warrior who ever
lived died and lived again he's a man so
individually deadly that not only is he
kept in a containment chamber under the
sea surrounded by highly trained and
armored guards he has his own localized
on-site nuclear weapon ready to blow
away and annihilate him and his entire
containment area if deemed necessary he
may not be a contagious anomalous
pathogen or a lethal memetic hazard or a
giant bees shooting world destroying
fireballs in every direction but if this
one-man massacre was left to his own
devices there's no doubt that he would
methodically slaughter his way through
the human race until an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario was
practically inevitable he was fueled by
pure hatred and an almost bottomless
bloodlust he simply lived to fight and
kill and not only did he have the will
and the skill to be a pure force of
annihilation but his anomalous abilities
also make him perfectly tailored to the
task he has massively enhanced physical
strength speed and durability taking the
kind of damage that would kill several
normal humans to reliably put him down
though even that is only a temporary
measure abel will always resurrect back
into his black sarcophagus to menace the
scp foundation another day it is also
effectively impossible to disarm abel
because he has the anomalous ability to
pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket dimensions at will and his
proficiency with these weapons is unlike
any warrior the world has ever known
before or since during containment
breaches he's regularly killed scores of
train foundation guards with both
numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons despite
being a simple humanoid he was taking up
a truly insane amount of containment
resources despite his violent tendencies
abel is still a recognizable sentient
human albeit an extremely deadly
anomalous one this led some higher-ups
at the foundation to come up with an
interesting idea what if abel's eternal
rage could be harnessed what if they
could use their resources to reshape
this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the foundation's cause after
all if he wanted worthy opponents what
could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the foundation faced on a
daily basis and as long as they kept the
sarcophagus even if abel was killed in
the line of duty he'd still be accounted
for in many ways if he could be trained
and truly brought to heal there could be
no better asset to their coming
struggles it was this logic allowing
anomalies to work for the scp foundation
in exchange for benefits that led to the
creation of a new groundbreaking mobile
task force mtf omega 7 pandora's box
this group became the scp foundation's
hail mary pass for any particularly
dangerous or potentially deadly missions
they could send in abel along with a
group of highly trained foundation
soldiers that even the ancient blade
wielding warrior held respect for while
like their namesake pandora's box it
would all wind up in terrible tragedy to
begin with they achieved some of the
highest mission successful results of
any mobile task force on the
foundation's payroll no task was too
challenging for them to swoop in and
crush it this was far from expected abel
one of the most violent scps they'd ever
contained suddenly became a great asset
to their operations a vital tool in
their quest to keep the anomalous at bay
he cleaved through legions of chaos
insurgency soldiers during breaches into
their secure sites he fought off
well-paid well-trained and well-armed
bodyguards of marshall carter and dark
limited during foundation raids on their
clandestine operations he'd even gone
toe to toe with some of the deadliest
anomalies in containment during mass
escapes it was hard to imagine how
they'd ever lived without him of course
while abel was happier than he'd had
been in years in his element in fact as
a working warrior giving varied missions
and frequent opponents there was still
something nagging at him his thoughts
were hounded by his white whale the
endless search for a truly worthy
opponent someone or something that could
really give him a run for his money
after millennia of leaving opponents
dead in this wake nothing would bring
him more joy than meeting someone that
actually knocked him on his ass a new
bar somewhere above him to work towards
oh what a glorious day that would be
eventually the foundation started to run
into a problem they were running out of
missions to give abel after all he
wasn't the kind of operative you could
just give any mission to his potential
for collateral damage was truly
staggering he'd neutralize the anomaly
then slaughter everyone within a hundred
foot range just to work off some of the
excess energy like a hand grenade he was
powerful but dangerously imprecise if
they ran out of high priority missions
what were they supposed to do just put
abel back in his box to gather dust
until someone else rolled around he was
getting antsy enough between missions
already that's when an unexpected member
of personnel stepped forward dr jack
bright you see dr bright and abel had a
history and not an altogether pleasant
one not that anyone could really have a
pleasant history with abel jack was only
a junior researcher when he had his
run-in carrying a seemingly worthless
medallion dubbed
scp-963 back to its containment locker
that's when a wall next to him exploded
showering him with brick fragments and
dust only to reveal abel standing behind
the new aperture before young dr bright
even had a chance to scream abel had
already cleaved through him leaving him
in two distinct parts that were both
very much dead at least it seemed that
way until it was revealed that dr
bright's consciousness had actually been
eternally bonded with scp-963
giving him the gift and curse of
immortality since then dr bright had
become increasingly reckless in his
conduct perhaps hoping that the next
time he fades to black the movie that is
his sad strange life won't just start to
roll again of course he hasn't been
lucky in that regard yet naturally this
has given dr bright complex feelings
about his fellow anomalous foundation
employee so when the call came around
all the senior researchers and site
directors asking if there were any tasks
that abel seemed fit for he had one very
pressing suggestion after all it wasn't
that long after dr bright had been
forced into a cross test with the
intention of terminating 682 which had
not only been a failure but a generally
painful and exhausting experience now
perhaps it would be able's turn to take
his lumps he happily put forth a
suggestion claiming that surely the
foundation's new sword-wielding golden
boy could give the hard-to-destroy
reptile the old college try after all
even if abel was killed in the process
he'd just come right back it was a
situation where they really could not
lose so why not take a chance what's the
worst that could happen the o5 council
found dr bright's pitch extremely
compelling he succeeded in every mission
they'd given him so far so perhaps he
could carry that success into the
herculean task of actually terminating
682 one boundlessly bloodthirsty killer
might be the only thing truly capable of
taking out another of equal magnitude
when abel was informed of this latest
mission he got a scary glint in his eye
they gave him warning after warning the
beast is said to be unkillable it can
adapt to anything it's killed scores of
people and survived the attacks of
anomalies thought to be flawless killers
the more it was explained to him the
more able felt the tingling sensation
deep within was this it had he now
discovered the perfect opponent
something that would actually challenge
him would actually put him through his
paces
yes yes
yes he accepted the mission without
question abel would fight
scp-682 until his breath was no longer
in order to prepare for the match
scp-682 was released into a secure area
rocky desert-like terrain boarded on all
sides by a foundation perimeter hundreds
of meters away on all sides they thought
it best for the showdown to happen here
after all with combatants like abel and
682 it was bound to make a mess one way
or another abel strode with pronounced
swagger onto the battleground shortly
afterwards carrying perhaps the most
powerful sword he'd ever summoned it was
somewhere between a claymore and a
chainsaw an unholy union that gave the
resulting weapon a degree of deranged
badassery not ever seen on the
battlefields of planet earth before
carrying this thing abel felt like a
king and he was about to slay the most
ancient and beastial of monsters as he
approached 682 and took in the hull of
it he could feel his heart pounding with
excitement in his chest it was a huge
reptilian nightmare he could see its
scales hardening into a mighty carapace
as he approached its huge serrated fangs
its bulging sinewy muscles and insane
dagger-like claws oh yes
this would be the one the beast snarled
at him as he approached he just smiled
puffed out his chest and said i have
heard tales of creatures like you
glorious beasts of scale and flesh talon
and fang a prowess in battle even
greater than the immense intellect
hiding behind those beasts you lies they
said your kind once ruled the earth from
enormous stockpiles of treasure killing
and eating all who displeased you but
you were knocked from your throne one by
one by the great warriors who walked
this world no longer until they were no
more and you became but a mere myth even
i had thought you to be nothing but
fairy tales but yet here you stand
before me a living dragon
in response to abel's lofty speech the
monster merely grumbled and chided him
claiming he was little more than a
pathetic scp foundation lapdog following
orders and being manipulated it showed
no respect for abel as a valued enemy
combatant merely another nuisance thrown
at it in a futile attempt to finish its
wretched and seemingly eternal life able
couldn't take such insolence he leapt
forwards bringing down his mighty
chainsaw claymore ready to cleave the
beast in two however what he didn't
expect was the move
scp-682 pulled next throwing its head up
against the blade of abel's sword
shredding away huge chunks of flesh and
bone and utterly confusing abel in the
process for the first time in a lifetime
of intense battles abel found himself
thinking what the hell am i up against
here the force of 682's headbutt threw
abel off balance leaving his stomach
briefly exposed but briefly was all cp
682 needed it thundered its massive
stony fist into abel's gut throwing him
like a ragdoll into a nearby rock with
such a force that it nearly shattered
the rock behind him it was a force like
he hadn't felt in years he spat some
bloody teeth and grinned this was just
what the doctor ordered he issued a
challenge to the beast in a long dead
language as it seized violently
regenerating growing taking on the stony
qualities of the ground around it it
looked like a vengeful living mountain a
true behemoth of a beast in other words
challenge accepted abel pulled an
obscenely giant mace from the shadows of
his cloak the handle six feet long with
a chaos of swirling blades and spikes a
perfect weapon for slaying a dragon like
this he thought to himself the two
charged at each other full of power and
fury able swung the mace once again
shattering the creature's head and
flinging it back across the battlefield
with the sheer force of its strike the
decimated lizard clawed its way into the
ground devouring the rocks and the earth
integrating more matter to fuel its
regeneration but it wasn't long before
abel was upon it again striking
mercilessly giving blows as the monster
gave brutal claw strikes in return they
were ripping each other's bodies apart
piece by piece but abel felt so
exhilarated he could barely even notice
it was the fight of his life a battle
against a truly worthy opponent this was
heaven abel leaped into the air and
unleashed a volley of deadly chakram
down onto the beast shredding into its
reinforced flesh as the force of gravity
brought him down he pulled a mighty axe
from his cloak and bellowed a warrior's
roar as he brought it down splattering
into the nightmarish body of scp-682
however this did nothing to even slow
the beast down it flipped over slashing
abel with its claws when abel stumbled
it leaped on top of him unleashing
devastating slashes and punches onto the
fallen warrior with the speed of a
machine gun firing when it raised its
claw to deal with the killing blow
though abel once again turned the tables
he produced a giant pair of mechanical
scissors from thin air and sliced off
both of
scp-682's forelegs the beast descended
with its mighty jaws to devour abel but
he kicked up with freakish strength
behind his bladed boot the sheer force
of the kick flipped scp-682
onto its back now it was able's turn to
execute his opponent though on some
level he thought it would be an awful
shame to lose such a terrific beast from
this world of cardboard still a battle
is a battle and this is how they go
he jumped onto 682 and went berserk
slashing into it relentlessly with blade
after blade pulling out a new one every
time the old one broke down from his
sheer ferocity he screamed an incoherent
battle fury tearing slicing ripping
rending
yes
yes
yes
yes
as abel stepped away to breathe the
beast began to regenerate releasing a
shockwave that started to warp reality
around it but abel wouldn't have this no
he would give this beast no quarter it
was time to present the true pain he was
notorious for he pulled a long sword
from his cloak and charged taking air
and bringing it down towards as cp 682's
had the bees sensing the warrior's
presence opened its mouth unleashing a
chasm of horrifying teeth within the two
were on a fierce collision course as the
jaws closed abel descended both roared
in infinite rage and bloodlust both
combatants fell to the ground just
twitching oh what a glorious terrible
day it had been neither had died for
good but both would remember this
incredible battle forever when abel
awoke once more in his dark stone coffin
he did so with a smile what a battle
what a fight what a truly honorable
pursuit after so long being bored and
unfulfilled he found an opponent that
got his blood pumping once more his
stomach grumbled a post-battle feast was
in order now where did they put that
magic pizza box now go check out scp-682
waze scp foundation try to kill hard to
destroy reptile and
scp-073-076 kane vs abel for more about
the two legendary combatants involved in
today's battle